some people just suck at video games
last player standing Elizabeth
they might have the wrong in-game
settings bad mechanics or maybe just the
wrong mentality I am hard stock silver
too and I don't know who to man who'd be
the best Main and how do I get out of
silver too listen to me bro I'm gonna
give it to you straight the agent the
character you're playing is not the
problem
are the problem so watch
so what well luckily
co-services have become widely available
for basically every major Esports title
from valorant to Counter-Strike to
League of Legends the list goes on but
do these Services actually work can
coaching really make you better at a
game or is it all just a waste of money
[Applause]
alright so before we start talking about
coaching Services I would like to remind
you all to please please please like the
video subscribe to the channel and turn
on notifications that way you'll never
miss an episode of craft okay so
coaching Services have actually existed
for quite some time and seem like they
should be pretty uncontroversial you
find someone who's really good at a game
pay them for their services they make
you better at the game
watching your rock hundreds of pros and
content creators offer their expertise
on coaching websites like medify but the
pricing of some of these Services is
what's sparked quite a lot of debate
some members of the community think that
many coaches just aren't qualified that
their prices are too high given that
they haven't proven themselves at a tier
one level now of course there's a pretty
wide range of experience amongst those
offering coaching some are Pros who have
competed in Tier 1 or tier 2 competitive
Play While others are better known for
content creation and that is where the
bulk of this discussion comes from
should any Immortal or radiant ranked
player be able to charge whatever price
they want can you get proper coaching
from someone who isn't necessarily on a
tier 1 VCT roster well we at the score
reports wanted to figure it out for
ourselves so we launched an
investigation into said coaching
services and tried to figure out whether
they're actually worth the money and
whether some of us might be able to
actually get good in the process to
start we took three of our hosts ranked
bronze gold and diamond and signed each
of them up for some valorant coaching
sessions ravish has been playing since
launch and over the last three years has
done quite a bit of valorant casting
that they move right away they don't
want no Peaks they actually want zero
smoke they see a fire they say bet I'm
Audi I'm not a firefighter y'all can
have that but despite all of his
experience ravish remains bronze he
really wants to improve I'm just not at
the same level as many of the people
that I play with and I want to be able
to help to contribute to the successes
right I don't want people to have to
feel like I heard of each wants to play
again let's keep the bottom frag worn
for him I don't use anybody friend but
still and also with Premiere out I do
want to help you know win with a team
right because who doesn't so ravish
primarily wanted to work on his aim and
general game sense and to help our boy
out we hired Roy the former igl of
Renegades girl kissers and of course
kitten shelter more recently Roy has
also appeared on many of night's
broadcasts as an analyst for na
Challengers for 35 raviche did an
hour-long live VOD review with Roy he
started by finding a sensitivity that
better suited reviews play style then
they focused on some Vandal recoil
control before hopping into Team
Deathmatch for a quick warm-up
okay so see that's my thing too is
because like within within like stay
brows and things like that it's like
people feel so comfortable just they're
just kind of training yeah
we're just doing that that's just this
is happening
yeah so one thing I've noticed with
people that are a little bit lower ranks
is you guys could be Corners using like
a diagonal line instead of like a like a
straight line so you want to make sure
you're always peaking with a or D okay
you don't want to be like pressing W or
S when you're beating anyone okay all
right it makes it it makes it a little
like less favorable for you okay all
right that's a great note Roy also threw
in a little pep talk to help ravish with
tilt delusion is the best medicine in
Ballard okay we're the best player in
the server at all times you hear me okay
yes sir we go in with full confidence
every fight we want to take we're we're
taking it with full confidence no
hesitation no resistance nothing no
mental resistance no mental [__] okay
when it's time to fight we're fighting
everything's cool we're the best player
in the server at all times let's do this
interestingly raviche went into this
whole thing thinking that he already had
a pretty good mental which is
potentially a point in favor of coaching
Services since X
players tend to be able to see cracks in
your game that you yourself might not be
aware of afterwards ravish entered
unrated locked in breach on Haven and
the two of them got to cook him you have
to think of this a bomb side as like a
2p sponsor right okay so there's like
the front sight and there's backside you
want to make sure you're giving uto for
the front sight and also for the
backside so like you flash for him to
get at the front sight and then you give
him another flash for the backside so
you want to make sure you're setting up
your duelist like fully before you're
like committing when you're without any
doubt or anything like that Roy directed
the session to be about playing with
confidence and then lo and behold RAV
did this
I'm one of the highest added jets in the
in the region but it's okay
oh
he didn't spawn enough
oh baby
that's clean bro I learned a lot in
terms of fundamentals and Asian
specifics and just trying to be a better
teammate overall right I wanted to hop
into this being more confident the way I
play how to take better Peaks and
there's harder come out of it knowing
how to take a gun fight at the end of
the day right because a lot of this for
me it's a learning fundamentals and
being able to contribute more just as a
player overall right and that's kind of
what I was aiming for we'll come back to
raviche later on in the video but for
now let's move on to a different host
Liz started playing valorent back in
January of 2021 shortly after she made
the switch from console to PC gaming she
typically sits around gold and Prides
herself on her ability to keep her
team's morale up and Control the Chaos
that often ensues when they queue up
together I'm holding this weird off
angle until she flashes then I'm leaving
you to die I'm sorry
[Laughter]
it's not even close well I think it's
sort of the same thing of why do you
have other people look at your papers
The Outfits you wear the text you send
everyone always wants an extra eye on
something and in this situation when you
can have one of the best Eyes the game
has ever seen looking at your work I
think anyone would take that offer Liz
really wanted to improve her shot call
she's usually her team's igl out of
necessity and really wanted to hone that
skill to help her out we hired foe the
former igl for built by Gamers and Evil
Geniuses Liz decided to try his
one-on-one live coaching and Improvement
plan for twenty dollars for one hour
after giving Liz a bit of feedback on
her mechanics in Team Deathmatch foe
took her into ranked and helped her tame
the gold rabble
so you want to make a statement in the
form of a question okay that's the idea
so let's say you see three rotate to a
and you want to take it you say there's
3A should we leave now
which the answer is like yeah let's
leave you want to be manipulative I know
that sounds weird but you do want to
manipulate your ranked teammates
be everyone be a manipulator oh let's
not go because I probably all rotated a
should we try C hit
you say yes yeah he went yeah
whoa another point in favor of coaching
just like Roy helped ravish with his
mental these are soft skills that are
hard to pick up on your own and an
experienced igl can tell you what
they've done in the past and pass that
wisdom on to you speaking of Liza scene
lost control of the game in the second
half which ultimately resulted in their
defeat and this was when foe also took
time to talk about her mental
self-deprecation is like the worst thing
you can do and I say that and I will
also say the same things right you have
to stop yourself from doing that when
you notice it
do not
self-deprecate when you are attempting
to go for improvement because all you
will do is create a false perception of
negativity surrounding the experience
and then you will dislike it after a
lengthy discuss question about Liz's
mental foe took her into a custom server
and started offering additional tips
despite the fact that their hour-long
session was technically over this is
something that he says he often does
with his students as long as he doesn't
have back to back sessions scheduled foe
went the extra mile and showed us how
some coaches really can teach you things
you can't learn on your own he even made
Liz an entire Improvement plan to
reference as she kept playing so at only
twenty dollars she definitely got her
money's worth if I was live feedback was
really really helpful so I could learn
in real time I was doing great or not so
great but I think most importantly foe
sitting me down and talking to me about
my own mental game and not being so mean
to myself is something that I really
really needed to hear
last up we have Nile Nile has
closed beta and is usually ranked mid
Diamond so with the new season of
Premiere underway I want to focus on the
agents that I play with my team and
learn more unique Jet and Cipher setup
so that maybe this time we can actually
make playoffs so to help him out we
hired Danny the former assistant coach
for Sentinels and G2 Nile chose to do an
hour of server work with Danny for forty
dollars they started off by jumping into
a custom on buying where Nile plays jet
so he showed off some of his defensive
op setups on both sides before Danny
gave him some tips and new ideas for
angles to hold if you're against the
Viper I do recommend instead of playing
top truck sometimes you like jump up
here yeah
and basically he's gonna have a Viper
wall here he's gonna have an orb here
so you're just like
opting on top of all his utility won't
expect it so the goal of this angle is
basically you see where the Viper throws
the door from you this throws it from
Market or like jungle side okay or he
throws it from Marcus so left or right
and wherever he throws it from you just
hold that angle
for cams and trips
showcased his own before Dany helped him
improve them
by that time let's say you have like two
teammates and spawn and they're smoked
off like always here right they're
always smoke top and yeah
for the retake so they can come yeah pop
this and they just flat out elbow now
they have like a free pass now Niall
already had more skill and experience
than our other test subjects and because
of that his coach could focus more on
helping him make small improvements and
break some of his sub-optimal habits my
session with Danny was honestly great he
was professional but still joked around
with me and kept things digestible for
some of my skill level and it was
honestly really cool learning some of
his old teammate Dappers Cipher setups
that was probably my favorite part so
all three of our hosts participated in
vastly different coaching sessions and
now it's time to see what they thought
about the overall experience they think
it was worth their money did it help
them improve and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
all right so we all did our coaching
sessions a few weeks ago now but how did
you guys Implement what you learned into
your future matches so I learned a lot
in terms of just fundamentals eating
specifics and just trying to be more
comfortable playing the game taking gun
fights and
I think I can now like peek a lot more
effectively contribute more to my team
and there's also a desire I'd say to
just be better like something that I
find I didn't have a ton of it before
and see how it can contribute more yeah
I think for me beyond the bad kind of
Basic Essentials of you know leveling up
my Astra game that foe was teaching me
in terms of you know setups placements
put your wall here kind of thing he
definitely kind of had a wake-up call
for me in terms of my mental being and
kind of being my own worst critic I
definitely am a bully to myself and I'm
much much rather than being critical I'm
just plain old mean to myself and that
doesn't help anyone I'm a lot kinder to
my teammates and I'm to myself and I am
part of that team and so definitely
working on being kinder to myself it
definitely has been a struggle honestly
I definitely am very used to being very
very mean as I have just the way I've
operated my entire life kind of coming
from an arts background
but
um
yeah it's definitely been uh it's been a
journey so far and kind of applying that
to my games I definitely see when I do
apply a little more
even neutral lens is definitely it
changes the way I see myself and my
gameplay
but what about you Nile I was dashing
all over sites making space for the team
and even opping the first week of
matches and then on split I kind of just
played like a rat and used some of my
favorite defensive setups to lock down
sections of the map and then on attack I
was just throwing cages and just being a
big rat
so all of us had pretty different
sessions but would you say that you got
your money's worth do coaching Services
really work yeah yeah I think they do I
think as far as as as long as you let
them work if you are going into a
coaching session with the right mindset
of I'm going to take the feedback that
is given to me and apply it into my
games and continue to apply it to my
games then yeah absolutely they're going
to work but if you're going in you're
not ready to apply that feedback you
kind of aren't ready to take criticism
or you're just there to meet your fave
which you're allowed to do
um then the purpose of coaching sessions
for you to become a better player that's
most likely not going to happen
um and again you can do whatever you
want with your money it is your business
but I believe coaching sessions work
when you actively participate in those
coaching sessions not just in that
session but afterwards and for a while
afterwards yeah that's a huge point
right naturally like you said now like
they're full answers so you can go up
and down in terms of those boards and
just see exactly who's charging for what
if you don't got a hundred dollars for
30 minutes that's fine if you only have
20 bucks for an hour that's also fine
because end of the day there's a coach
out there for you whether to be a player
an xigl or whoever who was part of the
scene and they all charge very
differently as well for different marks
of their times and different types of
sessions too that's the biggest thing it
doesn't have to be what I got about Liz
got what you got right it's just about
what you want what you need and
hopefully there is someone out there
that perturns to you usually there it is
also in your price range too yeah I
definitely feel like I got my money's
worth my Premier team basically didn't
have to worry about what I was doing
because I was usually making the correct
decision by copying a lot of the setups
that Danny showed me that just meant
that our igl didn't really have to
micromanage me and could just focus on
other things I know a lot of these
modify coaches sometimes get memed on
for some of their pricing but I honestly
feel like they should be able to charge
what they want they're Freelancers so
they should know their own worth and
that was the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about so do coaching
sessions work from our experience the
answer is yes all three of our hosts
felt like they improved after each of
their sessions and although the pricing
for these Services may vary they all
seem to think that the cost was pretty
reasonable in every case now of course
we didn't choose some of the more
expensive coaches because quite honestly
we thought the pricing was a little
steep but as Niall said these coaches
are Freelancers they should be able to
charge whatever they think their
sessions are worth ultimately it's up to
you to decide what you or willing to pay
for coaching like this and look not
everybody can afford to pay for
one-on-one coaching with Pros or content
creators on metaphy
you can still learn a lot of valuable
things everyone has their own preferred
learning style and if you find that
Hands-On lessons are what work best for
you then getting coached could really
help you improve the price versus value
debate May rage on but we can certainly
confirm that coaching works for us
uh this is a Call of Duty yeah this is
okay so he's they said it okay let's go
confirm that's true
that's your respawn
you know you're turned around for some
reason
my favorite guy he's on defense
[Music]